Let's talk now about normalization.
One of the most important and relevant concepts
that we've talked about during the current
administration is the realization that things
that are not normal are being normalized and
hyper normalize.
Now, some of this comes from numbness.
Humans adapt and things become, quote, normal
very quickly.
Even things we would not imagine would become
normal.
Part of it is the Trump administration working
to normalize, for example, corruption, the
way Trump insults people, the way Trump puts
his family and friends in positions of power
and privilege through his presidency.
Trump's violations regularly of the emoluments
clause, the weekly or sometimes almost daily
scandals with all of it.
We have to work hard not to become numb and
desensitized to the insanity, but also the
Trump administration wants to make these things
normal.
And the truth is, it works in part because
humans adapt incredibly well and very quickly
and outrageous situations become normal seeming
or normal feeling.
Any one of Trump's scandals from just the
last week alone would have been months of
coverage.
If Barack Obama were President Trump's Justice
Department saying, hey, you know what, we're
not going to prosecute Michael Flynn, who
already pleaded guilty.
By the way, that would have been an insane
scandal during the Obama administration.
Trump's press secretary lying in an unhinged
way and cutting short briefings, holding 20
minute briefings that start 40 minutes late.
That would have been three months on Fox News
about the lack of transparency and descend
the constant dishonesty of an administration.
Trump getting caught.
As I told you 10 minutes ago.
Bass essentially throwing out or suppressing
the CDC actual reopening guidelines.
There are others.
Any one of those would have been a month long
scandal for Barack Obama.
But they are blips for Donald Trump.
But the real normalization that is being planned
is make the corona virus deaths normal and
frame it as we're back in business.
We're reopening.
Everything's okay.
We have gotten past the peak and things are
good now.
And the Trump administration has been hinting
at this for a long time with their entire
we never shut down because of the flu stuff.
The cure can't be worse than the disease.
We're past the peak.
We've handled it well.
Things are improving.
The plan has been for a while now.
Just don't talk about the virus itself anymore.
Talk about reopening.
Talk about businesses, talk about CEOs.
Talk about how we have ventilators coming
after the bleach injection fiasco.
They essentially stopped the normal press
briefings and replaced them with propaganda
events like a CEO roundtable.
A day of prayer at the White House later today
or maybe earlier today if you're listening
in the evening or tomorrow.
Trump is finally doing a press briefing, but
it will be to make a testing related announcement,
no doubt more testing propaganda.
And now, again, they are talking about car
crash deaths, cancer deaths, suicide, all
things that, of course, are not highly contagious
and are not communicable.
It is coordinated.
You've got Republican senators using at Fox
News recently put up an image that compares
heart disease and cancer deaths to those from
Corona virus.
And meanwhile, the deaths keep climbing.
We've now passed the eighty thousand death
mark.
Remember, Trump was saying for a month or
longer we're gonna have 60 thousand.
Then when it was clear we would have more,
he said we could have 70 to 80.
Now he's talking about 90 to 100.
Most models now we're talking about one hundred
and thirty thousand during wave one.
So the plan that now is the one being put
in place by this administration is just pretend
everything's.
They failed.
You look at other countries.
You look at Italy, Spain, Germany, France,
others.
Their curves actually make sense in the context
of dealing with the issue.
And Trump has failed.
Trump has failed.
So they are not going to talk about it.
They will make it the status quo.
Just like, listen, people die in car accidents.
People die of Corona virus.
Could this work?
It certainly can work for a while.
The problem is that ignoring the virus and
the deaths leads to more of it because people
spread the disease.
Trump's calculating that, ignoring it and
inviting CEOs to the White House is going
to get him reelected in November.
News channels presumably will continue reporting
the death numbers and Trump can suppress it
as much as he wants.
Eventually, it's going to catch up with him
eventually as other countries open their borders
to countries that have this under control.
But they keep their borders close to the United
States.
Americans are going to realize, I think something
will be wrong when Canadians are allowed to
fly to Germany and Brits can fly to Japan.
But Americans aren't allowed to fly anywhere.
You would imagine that that will eventually
have an impact.
And by the way, we still aren't doing enough
testing.
We are now getting to 300000 tests per day.
It's taken more than two months to get there.
We need to be at 500 thousand a day as a minimum
en route to 1 million a day or two.
We are just now approaching 300000 tests today.
Even the simpler things they're not doing.
And so this is the new strategy.
It's going to be up to up to us to decide
whether we fall for it, whether whether we
allow it essentially, because even though
we know that car crashes and corona virus
deaths are not the same thing, takes a lot
of work not to start to become numb to many
of these numbers.
And of course, everybody who is directly affected
by the virus is not going to become numb to
the numbers.
But a lot of people are just in fantasy land.
They don't know anyone who's died from the
virus.
And unfortunately for a lot of these right
wingers, until it affects them personally,
it's just not real.
They just don't care.
And it's gonna be up to you and to me and
to everybody else to decide, do we allow this
to become the norm or do we say this has been
an abject failure and this administration
must be removed five and a half months from
now?
That's how far away we are at this point,
five and a half months.
Let me know what you predict.
I'm on Twitter at De Packman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.